Joe Biden speaking of had the second
physical of his presidency today it was
conducted a Walter Reed National
military Medical Center as it's now
called according to the White House
physician the physical
demonstrates that Joe Biden is whenever
quoting a healthy vigorous 80 year old
male which may seem a little bit like
some oxymoron but whatever he is afib
spinal arthritis and a few other
conditions apparently he did not take
notably a cognitive test the White House
is not making the White House physician
available for questions
of course but we have thank heaven Dr
Mark Siegel to assess he joins us
tonight doctor thanks for coming on what
do you make of this Tucker you already
got the key point which is this physical
exam is more significant for what it
leaves out than what it actually tells
us and it tells us he's got allergies
he's got reflux he's got spinal stenosis
in his spinous arthritis in his spine
and they're trying to say on this
physical something that we've been
talking about for a year which is
where's the stiff gate he has coming
from and they're saying it's coming from
peripheral neuropathy meaning loss of
sensation in his feet which they don't
know where that's coming from and
arthritis in the spine here's my problem
with that they're basing that on a
physical examination of multiple doctors
but no MRI I don't see anywhere in there
about an MRI since the 1980s I want to
tell you Dr O'Connor we don't just
examine patients extensively and say no
multiple sclerosis no stroke you know no
problems with water on the brain that
could be causing cognitive problems we
do an MRI where's the MRI and also you
already said it where's the cognitive
test we have a cognitive error a day at
least from this president who the other
day said 20 000 pounds of fentanyl was
enough to kill a thousand people how
about four billion people or he calls
Kamala Harris the president or he
forgets a congressperson's name or one
that has died he thinks is in the
audience I mean this is really extensive
and it's getting worse his own son who
he named the cancer moonshot after he
says died in Iraq this has got to be
examined and then listen to this a stiff
gate is sometimes a sign of cognitive
problems an MRI a cognitive test now
listen Tucker I know 80 year olds that
are operating still we know 90 year olds
who are amazing but it's not about age
even though most Americans say he's too
old to run again I say it's about
Fitness Tucker yeah it's so obvious that
it's insulting really to the to the rest
of us we appreciate your expertise in
analyzing these so-called results Dr
Mark Siegel thank you subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight